[Music]
first stars like Chris Hemsworth Naomi
Campbell Leonardo DiCaprio they all love
racing and have turned out for the
formula e racing series we teamed up
with visa to see what the hype is about
DT on lines Deidre Behar was in the
middle of the action professional
drivers in electric cars whipping around
insane speeds there's an hour plus a
minus 220 those kind of speeds it's no
wonder why this sport is attracting
major stars to the truck if you could
get out there and race any celebrity who
would you choose and why
well we're in booking so I think JC
would be a great set partner to be
fighting against in the track but before
Nelson issues JC an official challenge
what do you think do you think you're
winning what do you think I'm win it oh
you know you're winning admittedly I
lost the bet I'm a terrible driver do
you agree I wouldn't even consider the
driver I'm gonna bet though I owe you
something the easiest way to pay visas
cashless payment system they're
spearheading a movement reimagining the
world as a cashless culture we give you
a safe secure seamless transaction in
just a few seconds all I do is just
simply tap and I've paid whitening for
hours
the truck backs yours better luck next
time for me
[Music]
you